did you ever like
you know obviously coming from sdsu uh
marshall faulk
yeah kawhi leonard yeah you ever link
with any of those guys
i mean like marshall [ __ ] used to come
to talk to us and [ __ ] like that all the
time so like you feel me i know who bro
is and um uh like kawhi kawhi like quiet
yeah he's interesting guys he's like you
got to be his friend
to be around yeah but i didn't see him
like [ __ ] putting me back up like park
on the
in front of the gym like ain't no
parking lot like he's gonna put a
maybach up in front of the gym
so like you feel me i ain't seeing kawhi
and [ __ ] like that and just seeing bro
like
i was still playing football because he
ordered me like he graduated when i got
there
gotcha so you feel me like oh you seen
him come back he's originally from the
ie
right yeah yeah so yeah but like you
feel me
like aq and [ __ ] like i [ __ ] with aqaq
play basketball up there and he would
make music and [ __ ] now until you rap
that's my boy though you feel me but he
knew all of them so just
me [ __ ] with him i got to see them
sometimes like him and then
like dwayne polly like that's going to
be no like good homies and [ __ ] like
that and then
i feel like when we talk to blue bucks
did they say that they played did they
did
because they used to play football yeah
they used to play football with you
right football against each other and
[ __ ] like that
yeah like oh god i was trying to play
with them but i ended up playing for
mona park i played if i was trying to
play for the demos with them [ __ ]
played for the demos
i ended up playing from the park i mean
my cousin ended up going over there
because we moved to compton
but like bro the world's so small me and
one take [ __ ] play
football together that [ __ ] crazy every
little this [ __ ] is small
like like small